it's the first of the month you know
what that means rents due
what's up guys I'm tired Matthew also
known as the landlord they called me the
landlord cuz I own the field and I take
care of cheese Kingdom so right now my
social responsibility goes much beyond
that a lot of people have been impacted
by coal bit 19 especially in my hometown
of New Orleans I'm hoping to find a few
families that I could really impact and
help and love and support I'm looking
forward to checking them out hey tyrant
what's going on I heard that you are
looking for families to support in the
local community where you're from a
particular family that sticks out as
miss Ruth ball and her twins
Jan's Ania and ZAF Ania though miss Ruth
works in the hospitality industry she's
nowhere near working enough to support
her family and her twins and her 18 year
old in the past two months the most that
she's been able to work a week or 20
hours a week you know New Orleans has a
lot of families that could use some help
and there's certainly one of them so
thank you for your time go Tigers and we
appreciate your time how's everybody
doing we good
how's everything going in New Orleans
right now they back hoping but you know
works nice but you know New Orleans they
stay busy how you guys doing
come on yeah
keep the smiley face
I heard you work at Hotel Monteleone
alright yeah we're good at modeling
that's like the most legendary Hotel in
the waters right yeah it is the crystal
bar you know we stay busy at the top
with the kids right now as far as them
just you know having being able to kind
of release their energy and you know go
outside oh yeah yes it is cuz you know
they like the outside and the bright
Boys and Girls Club and everything they
miss all of that so you like to play
sports they like me they like to be
outside daddy likes to be outside been
nice to your mom yeah that's important
okay cuz your mom actually has to stay
strong for you guys so you know she
needs you guys love and support she
needs you guys to be nice okay miss root
I want to get personal with you if
that's okay all right sure because I
heard that your hours were cut now
well yes I actually got an email
yesterday - sorry that they have to lay
us off terminan because they be open but
they're not gonna have jobs for us so as
26 of which is next week
you know we'll be on a temporary because
you know the adult industry so we don't
know scrap we don't know when it's gonna
picked up you know I'm really sorry to
hear that and I think I can help you if
I guess I can if you would if you would
take the help you know my nickname is
the landlord and everything on the field
and I take on the kingdom and I heard
your story and
I just had to reach out because in my
mind you deserve so much more I want you
to check your text if you if you could
for me before so it's really a blessing
and God bless very appreciated from my
family my kids you know we excited well
I sent you one much rent and my friends
at Zell are actually gonna match the
donation so you cover for two months
thank you god bless you
check your account after we hang out and
this should be enough for you guys
[Music]